Imagine, if you will - a gift.
I'd like for you to picture it in your mind.
It's not too big - about the size of a golf ball.
So envision what it looks like all wrapped up.
But before I show you what's inside, I will tell you, it's going to do incredible things for you.
It will bring all of your family together.
You will feel loved and appreciated like never before...
...and reconnect with friends and acquaintances you haven't heard from in years.
Adoration and admiration will overwhelm you.
It will recalibrate what's most important in your life.
It will redefine your sense of spirituality and faith.
You'll have a new understanding and trust in your body.
You'll have unsurpassed vitality and energy.
You'll expand your vocabulary, meet new people, and you'll have a healthier lifestyle.
And get this - you'll have an eight-week vacation of doing absolutely nothing.
You'll eat countless gourmet meals.
Flowers will arrive by the truckload.
People will say to you, "You look great.
Have you had any work done?"
And you'll have a lifetime supply of good drugs.